[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
boustany beaux essais de la muscu sunna
ah bah il arrêter un peu puisqu'il un
peu il un peu handicapé en ce moment
mais sinon oui bonjour a tous moi je
veux vous parler un petit peu de ce
qu'il fallait louper ce qu'il fallait
pas louper à la télé à l'image d'un
petit peu d'un calcul mental de magali
berda 1,6 x 7,6 aurait dès l'école il
aurait reçu par ailleurs qu il ya un
mois mais cela en fin d'émission ça
marche oui car on va commencer avec eux
les marseillais ils sont de retour avec
une nouvelle bande son en asie et il ya
un nouveau dans la bande d'enfants
d'asie et en asie
ah ouais c'est bien c'est la blessure
non celle des oreilles adacore et du
coup il ya un petit nouveau dans la
bande il veut impressionner tout le
monde s'appelle voilà c'est ça il va il
connaît tout le monde avec ses des
conneries vous mettre moins de 12 ans
[Rires]
laissez faire laissez à et du coup bah
lui il est à fond les ballons et il a
voulu faire une référence par rapport à
des films sauf que je crois qu'il a vu
la version low cost est pas la version
originale plus les regarde
j'ai jamais vu une maison si bête mais
quelle magnifique
elle est magnifique la maison mais c'est
quoi cette maison mais c'est la maison à
tony mentale hossa a pas de chez nous
[Musique]
voir
on a tonné mental aussi je veux vraiment
un effort ensuite on est dedans on est
sans la trouver la meilleure candidate
de tous les temps je défie motus je n'ai
pas trouvé la vérité 1 à seulement n'ont
même pas diffuser une émission mais non
il ya très très longtemps mais j'ai aimé
rire urnes h
celle là elle est pas mal à ses
meilleurs candidats de tous les temps
mais elle a vraiment un problème par
rapport aux mots je vous rappeler des
règles il faut trouver un mot donc
parfaitement dans les cases sahel s'est
toujours pile poil un jour une place
qu'il faut la commère co2 m
le rcs trop long
sortilège échouèrent pays est le jeu est
trop long visière vision7 mélanger pour
fêter ça à bernadette vie en général
[Musique]
exactement
exactement ce que j'ai c'est vraiment ce
que j'ai vécu dire que je ne trouvais
pas à seulement les cambistes et babel
maquis produire d'émissions je vous dis
pas la la honte
on attend à moi assez benoît et
magazines dans une équipe à bâle
[Rires]
allez bon c'est la grande mode en ce
moment pour nagui et son public vraiment
ils sont à fond les ballons un peu comme
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs est tout le
temps à fond les ballons vous avez deux
fois du coup mon il ya un mec dans le
pays a un mec dans le public je pense
que la veille l'arrière des balances
propose jusqu'à à peu près 4 heures du
matin et ça laisse des traces sont
fondées contacté il développe comme ça
de cette façon leur réseau ils
travaillent ensemble après et signent
des contrats
voilà d'accord y'a rien de ludique à la
tricherie
des tarifs et un sourire communicatif
pardon savez vous donner quand on
enregistre les émissions un peu tôt dans
la journée gm le public qu'on a c'est le
public qui s'est affaissée vous explique
pourquoi parfois des publics un peu plus
endormis c'est que en début de journée
on a des gens qui travaillent pas pour
sa musique et merci pour moi quand je
suis bon public et valorise à ça ça
vient des citrons de n'être pas d'emploi
c'est pas comme évidemment pas ça pour
vous dans le public que la moitié
qu'étant payet
[Musique]
en effet
lui c'est celui qui essaye de ne pas
être le plus jeune équipe plus vieux qui
disent à alléger dernière image et on a
trouvé le chat le plus intelligent du
monde
je pense que lui si on avait eu d'un
prêt à y mettre ses chaussettes c'est
chouette héritage de phu bài apparemment
lui s'il était dans prison break
on avait mais n'avait pas vraiment
besoin de se tatouer les plans de sortie
arrivés juste à servir de sa tête
regardez
ami qu'est c'est le chemin alors ça
c'est pas de chamois pardon
[Applaudissements]